is not having the captain Jac the lineup finishing
up his two game suspension and the ads move in
quickly a save made by Shon the rebound went to
the other side quit it oh I I had just sturken on
the line and it was quick who made a great save
linran and Fox on the fence the puck def Flex
out of play on the boards and there is Zack paresi
wearing number nine he signed a one-year deal with
the Avalanche weo Ranson in who scored 55 goals
last season in Port man Rangers got the other way
Fox going in deep the shot cut through gorev made
the save linran on the outskirts with pride Loose
by zanah jet missed by McKinnon Racing for crder
crder against McKinnon crder is in save goria
great move by Chris Grider taking an early penalty
and and the Rangers get a good opportunity here
McKinnon the forward is back on defense and krider
takes advantage with a really good move to his
back one shot by Taves and the save made by Qui
and the power play is over one shot on goal that
last one excellent job of penalty killing for
the Rangers that drop pass brought in and the
shot by Janson was stopped DeAndre Miller
moves in looks around toward the net and the
save the net was wide open and the rebound was
blocked there's the pass by Miller there's the
opportunity and coo kako was there and missed
on the open net just have trouble handling it
and the shot was missed F on by Lon Here Comes
aan crder wide to the right the pass to kryder
save goria oh he's made a couple of Duties on
CER offensive zone on an offensive Rush here's
another on man rush and this will be a good
little pass coming up from Savanah Jad who
finds krider krider no hesitation on the shot
but neither one in the lineup tonight Macky
another one that was singled out for Praise
by Peter L wraparound try was stopped nice
save Colton outside marar throw trick was on him
this is Colton set up in front save on Johansson
clock to the center by Colton binski gets it
ahead KY is in B can sa and Josh Manson comes
out with a puck nice move by Manson his pass
block and a save my quick it's a great action
to watch but I think the coaches might have
something to say great move by McKinnon and he
scores the man we talked about is now tied for
the league lead in scoring with 85 points Nathan
mckinon she'll get the puck watch the move right
there and then the quick hands I mean he just he
he shoots the puck in the middle of a stick handle
there's the move and then look at up quick bang
in and might have even deflected off of he take
the puck away from Fox and fox Bing through and
Rangers having trouble getting out of the Zone
Mara is set up saved by quick saved by quick on
another one and it has the rebound he on top of it
in the crease and the Rangers turn it over that's
Mar on the left watch he'll get it here and pardon
me I think he did take the shot got your coaching
hat on every now and then I think I know something
not very often but every now and then out in front
look at that shot by McKinnon a save by quick
and he decides to stop play there's Ranon makes
the play and then McKinnon just good individual
matchups Ranon batt Schneider for it zabad takes
it back now wheeler to crer and he couldn't
get the shot off but nobody see it and then
here's that poche we've seen him use his stick a
number of times in this game Blake wheeler plays
it ahead Wheeler's got a chance down low wheeler
shoots sa with a left hand by goria Rangers have
to T touch up get on side a minute and a half to
go here in the second good play by Miles wood he
moves in onug Guston in front save by quick here's
the turnover kie and Jones have a problem with it
wood intercepts and then he puts it right to the
net that's oconor going hard to the net here's
the pass again ' Conor right there and this
save by Jonathan Quick keeps this game at one-
nothing Aron went down gets up tro takes
a hit from Manson Lind down low but the
deflection and a save by gorgia offensive zone
pressure here's the shot and the deflection
good heads up play by lingren gson got it
through wheeler in deep sets up to V save
oh big chance and gorv again comes up with
a big save moved up the boards cleared out
by Miles wood and Zack Jones back for it yeah
that yeah that's that's the best thing or best
opportunities of had in a while that thing
was up high that was his first shot attempt
of the game here comes mckinon and a save by
quick just under N9 minutes to go face off win
by zabana Jad panarin on the line with zabana
Jad and crrider Sh for the score by timing pan
he's the man now the Rangers win the faceof
they don't get a shot here they'll put it in
deep and Panera will get it and here he goes
holds on holds on turns on the feed that's
kale Mar after him and with traffic in front
paner he has shot it more often this year look
like it might have got a bounce off M Ken
and into the net koram didn't see it the B
moves it up wheer was stopped by m Ron in deep
McKinnon pass it front save by quick that was
the game saer remember that save at the end
of the second period to keep it one nothing
Rangers turn the puck over and now we've seen
that combination an awful lot over the years
but Inon to ranin and there's Jonathan Quick
brought in by troch back to CER he shoots save
by gorv out to Miller for a shot save it's
juggled it's loose and it goes wide of the
net just gets a piece of it here's McKinnon
again and the setup save oh quick with a
great save Jonathan Quick with the save
and this time it's McKinnon with the pass
and Devon Taves gets the shot looking
to lead C there goes quick and he got
it through L Fier now to Zack drops it off L
Fier Cuts in shoots left for with did it over
time
throughout the game and let's see makes a
play there didn't get quite all of it to laer
and then just a little give and go what a move
here to the inside and the shot with players D
cutting in front the flyby screen you'll see
it here watch the player thr right in front
of gorgia right there that throws him off just
momentarily and then the perfect shot by laier